Hello world,
it's Saroj and we're going to try to
predict earthquakes in this video using
data science.
Now this is an ongoing challenge on the
popular data science competition website,
Kaggle.
It's called La n l earthquake prediction.
And the idea is to use an existing
datasets of seismic activity to try to
predict when an earthquake
will happen and their people.
This is an ongoing challenge. There
are people who are, as we speak,
submitting their best work to try to
predict an earthquake using this provided
dataset. And in this video we
have three learning objectives.
The first learning objective is to get
some idea as to how to think like a data
scientist.
That's the first one.
The second one is to understand
the cat boost algorithm,
which stands for categorical
gradient boosting. It's very popular.
Don't worry if you don't understand that.
We're going to go into that.
And the third objective is to understand
the support vector machine algorithm,
specifically support vector regression,
not classification,
which is usually used for. So those
are our three main learning objectives.
There's going to be a lot of math,
there's going to be code.
And we're going to do that all in
this video in a seven step process.
As you can see here,
we're going to go from zero installing,
solving all of those
dependencies to exploring the
Dataset and then implementing
the math and the code, et
Cetera. So it's super exciting.
And if you haven't subscribed, okay,
so let's get into this. So they're,
our first step is to try to understand
the background of this problem.
So predicting earthquakes has long
been thought to be near impossible,
but if we were able to predict earthquakes
than we could save countless lives
and properties, these are very
destructive forces of nature.
So there are many ways of predicting
the magnitude which equates to how
destructive and earthquake is.
So we can see here our first equation
for magnitude that I'm circling with my
mouse pointer log based,
10 of a over a zero,
a zero is the base quake.
The standard calibration earthquake for
testing purposes and a is the intensity
of the actual earthquake.
So when we divide those two values
and take log base 10 of them,
we get the magnitude and there are
different ways of writing this equation.
As we can see here, we can denote
it as I, we can set, I equal to,
I base zero times 10 to the m,
et Cetera.
And so that doesn't necessarily
have to do with this problem.
It's just really interesting to
note as background knowledge.
So when we take that magnitude and we
try to see what the places with the worst
earthquakes are, we'll find that
San Francisco is number two.
Chilay is number one. And this is
a bad thing, right? So we wanted,
this is a picture of an earthquake and
we want to try to predict when this is
going to happen.
So the idea is that given seismic signals,
we're asked to predict the time
until the onset of earthquakes.
Now these earthquakes or actually
laboratory earthquakes. So in the lab,
two plates were put under pressure
and this resulted in sheer stress.
And we can see what this looks like by
playing this little video right here,
right at three 24 he's
demonstrating this process
wish on the end of the sample
and cause it to share like that.
And so that sharing would be
motion on the undefault surfing.
So it's just like that,
just like in the lab.
And so we can see the training data is
just a single sequence of signal and it
seems to come from one experiment.
However,
the testing data consists of several
different sequences called segments that
may correspond to different experiments.
And we can see a preview of that
right on the website if we go to data.
And so here on this Kaggle page we can
see a sample of what it looks like and
all of these segmentations have a segment
id and then there's a time to failure.
Okay, so there, there are two features
there, right? So two columns there.
Okay.
And so we want to try to figure out the
relationship between those two columns.
So before we begin, definitely check
out these two helpful resources.
So the first one is called Kaggle,
colonels.
And what these are are basically
Jupiter notebooks and it's a way for the
community on Kaggle to share what they've
done with this challenge and they're
super cool.
Definitely check them out.
They definitely gave me a lot of ideas
as to how to approach this problem and
they will for you as well.
How to think about this problem.
It's a great initiative.
And the second one is the website papers
with code that the community is really
digging,
including me right now.
And if you have an idea for a different
type of model or whatever model you want
to use, this is the website to search for,
right? So let's say that I want to use,
I don't know,
genetic algorithms.
Okay.
For supervised learning.
Then I can just type in genetic supervised
and see what shows up.
Okay.
So two papers showed up and we can see
the paper and the code, which is awesome.
This website is awesome. I endorse this
website, I approved this message. Okay.
So, um, so those are the two that
definitely check those out. All right, so,
so there we go with that.
And now we are on to step one.
Here we go for about to install an import,
our dependencies.
So of course we need to install Kaggle
because that's how we're going to
actually retrieve this data set. And
by the way, if you're watching this,
I want you to open up
colab.research.google.com and
just do this with me because
you can,
this is all in the cloud.
You don't have to worry about
configurations or dependencies.
It's all happening in the cloud.
Okay?
So I mean locally you
don't have to worry about,
so let's install that and now
we're going to install the num Pi,
but the latest version to perform
some math operations specifically for
statistical features, which
we'll talk about. And lastly,
we're going to install the cat,
boost the library,
which will allow us to use cap
boost. Great. We installed that.
So now that we've installed
those dependencies,
we can start importing all of
the ones that we're going to use.
So of course we're going to import pandas
because that's for data preprocessing.
We're also going to import num Pi,
which is going to be four matrix math.
Now for machine learning cat boost,
we're going to use just like we installed
specifically it's regressor which
cause, because this is going to be a
regression model, which I'll talk about
and pool which I'll
also talk about and uh,
I guess for scaling we
will want to use psych.
It learns preprocessing,
uh, what was it called?
Standard scaler.
Okay.
Uh, what else? For hyper
parameter optimization,
we'll want to use grid search.
That means finding those ideal
hyper parameters for arc,
a cap boost algorithm also for
arch support vector machines.
Speaking of a psychic learn,
how does that second learn?
Has Everything seriously? It's
got it all. It's got it all.
And for Colonel Ridge. Okay,
so I got to talk about that.
We're not going to talk about that right
now, but we will at the, at the end.
But Colonel Ridge is
kernel methods are a way of
improving support vector
machine predictions and
making sure that we can create
a classifier line or regression line in
a feature space that we can visualize or
in a lower dimensional featured space.
So coronal ridge.
Okay.
And then of course data visualization.
We're going to import for this
specific use case map plot line.
Great. Okay. So those
are our dependencies.
That worked. Awesome. So
now we're on to step two,
importing our dataset from Kaggle, right?
So we want to collect that data set.
So to do that we're going to use
Google colabs own file access feature,
which is awesome, which lets us
import files directly into coke colab.
Now once we've done that,
we can create an object called uploaded
that will receive the result of whatever
we upload and then we can perform this
command line operation that will move
that Kaggle dot. Jason Haas, I'll
talk about what I'm, what I'm,
what I'm doing in a
second. Uh, doc, Kaggle
and hand.
C H mod 600.
Okay.
So what we're going to do now is run this
and we're going to upload our Kaggle
Dot Jason File. So what this is,
is a way for Colab to know what
your authentication details are.
It's the first thing you do is you go to
my account and then you click on create
new API token and it will download
that API token has a Jason file.
So then we'll go back and we'll upload
that Kaggle dot Jason File. All right,
so once we've uploaded
our Kaggle dot Jason File,
we can access the Kaggle Api directly
using Kaggle competitions list,
and it's going to show all
of the competitions that
exist there. Now that, that,
that was just for, you
know, demo purposes.
Now we can actually download
the earthquake data.
It's a great,
now it's downloading that data directly
from Kaggle into my colab run time
environment. And once I have that, so I'm
going to see where it is on my system.
Looks like. Okay, there we go. We got it.
We got to unzip this, uh, training file.
So we'll use the unzipped
command, uh, to, to, to unzip it,
trained.csv.zip.
And then we'll see what it looks like.
And once it's done on Zipping, we can
see it right here, totally unzipped.
And we can now go on to step three,
which is performing
exploratory data analysis.
So our first step is going to be to
extract that training data into a pan,
does data frame so we can look at it,
visualize it,
and then eventually perform
some statistical analysis on it.
Okay.
So for Eda, we've got our handy
dandy, a pandas function here,
specifically read CSV, one of the
most used functions and data science.
And we know the name of our file
as we can see it right above us.
It's called train dot CSV.
And how many data points do we want to
import a, this is a pretty big file.
So let's just say 6
million because why not?
And then we're going to say,
well, let's name our data types.
Our first data type is going
to be called acoustic data.
Okay.
And that data type is going to be a an
integer 16 bit integer and our next data
type is going to be
called time to failure.
Yeah,
I mean we can name these anything we want,
but we're just going to call it that
and since this is a very floaty number,
we're going to call it floats 64 there's
a lot of decimal places here and once
we have that we can try and
print out the first 10 entries.
Let's say 10 and there we go.
That's our data set right there.
The first 10 entries and these values
are are all going to change and now our
next step is to visualize this data.
Now specifically we want to visualize
the first 1% of samples in this data.
Now I've already written out this part
in particular right here because data
visualization is not a super hard,
right? We can do this in Tablo.
Drag and drop interfaces exist on
a zero and all of these platforms.
So I just wrote this out here and when
we plot this out, when we compile this,
okay,
when we compile this,
we'll see that right before the time to
failure, right before this blue line,
this time to failure,
that is when the biggest uh,
acoustic a quake quake happens.
So we know that there is a,
a point before the actual earthquake where
there's a spike in acoustic activity,
seismic seismographic activity.
Now,
if we were to visualize not just that,
but all of the data,
not just the first 1%,
we'll see that actually
yeah,
at right before the earthquake,
which is that this blue line is vertical
Blue Line right before this vertical
Blue Line, the earthquake,
every time there is a,
there is a spike in acoustic activity.
So there that,
there is our pattern right there.
And,
and eda exploratory data analysis
helped us visualize this pattern.
So we know that the way it
goes is spike in activity,
earthquake and this just keeps happening.
Other questions we could ask is,
is this interval constant to any other
factors affect this? Right? We're,
we're framing our question by
using exploratory exploratory
data analysis bit by
bit.
Okay,
so we'd done that part and now let's
move on to feature engineering.
But before we do that,
I also want to give out,
give out a shout out to Anton law loss.
So his colonel was really interesting.
What he did was he,
he had the intuition to say that
the data looks like sound waves.
It's also waiting as we can see
in this visual analysis here.
So he converted it into an audio file.
He didn't always did.
Then he animated the wave and
compared it to a dubstep song,
which is interesting. So the,
his idea was that, you know,
perhaps just like a dubstep song,
we can hear the buildup of an
earthquake before the drop.
So that's a really cool colonel
that I would definitely check out.
It's right here,
it's called audio analysis with animation.
Okay.
He's got a bunch of samples here. We can
even play it to see what it sounds like
and then we can play to see what
it sounds like with the dubstep.
Okay,
so interesting. Anyway, data is
amazing. So now onto step four,
feature engineering.
So remember we only had those two columns,
but there are a lot of features we
could have that could help increase the
accuracy of our regression model,
which we're going to build in a second.
So which features do we want to add?
Now there are a lot of
tried and true features,
statistical features that have
improved models in the past.
So what we're gonna do is
we're going to add about nine,
maybe 10 statistical
features to our data set.
So it's going to be a lot more features.
And hopefully the idea is that this is
going to improve the capabilities of our
model. It's going to have
a better prediction value.
So let's do all of that in
a single function called
generate features given our
dataset.
Okay,
so that's what we call
a generate features.
And we're going to say ass train is going
to start off as a list and we're going
to continually append that
list with a series of features.
And I'll explain what each
of these features are.
So of course the mean is the
average value of our data set,
the standard deviation tells us how
spread our Dataset is from the mean.
Okay.
The minimum value is just the
minimum value in our dataset.
Kurtosis I'm going to explain
in a second that's an,
that might be a newer one for you if you
haven't been in this space for a long,
long time. Uh, what else? Skew.
That's a, that's a fun one.
What else?
Um,
maybe tile values a value
or two and we'll split it.
It's just like that
Quan tile and that's it.
This is add those.
And we will now return
what this looks like
and there we go.
So let me explain what each of these
features are and then we're going to talk
about how we can add them to our data set.
So of course the mean
is sigma notation here.
We take all those values and
divide by the number of them. Uh,
the median is the middle number, right?
If when we ordered them sequentially,
what is the middle number?
The Standard Deviation is tells us how
spread out our data is. So here's a,
here's a visual representation
of the standard deviation.
So here it says 99.7% of the data
for this example case is within our,
within three standard
deviations of the mean.
So if this data set
looked much more spread,
this,
this distribution of data,
then it could be up to 15
standard deviations or 20 or
you know, a bigger number.
So it's how spread our distribution is.
That's the standard deviation.
And the way we find that is twoF is just
take the mean and subtract each data
points, square it, add
them all up together,
and then divide by the number
of data points minus one,
take the square root of the whole thing.
That's our standard deviation.
Kurtosis then uses the standard
deviation to compute itself.
We use that the STD to compute a kurtosis
where and so the way this works is we
take the mean and we say take each data
point minus the mean over the number of
data points and do that for as many data
points as there are sigma notation and
divide by the standard deviation.
The fourth power.
Now the Kurtosis tells us
it's a measure of whether the,
whether the data is heavy tailed or
light tailed relative to a normal
distribution.
As you can see in this picture,
positive Kurtosis is higher negative
is lower normal distribution.
And the reason this is
important is because it tells
us how many outliers we can
expect in our data.
Data sets with higher Kurtosis
tend to have heavy tails
or at outliers, right? So,
and the opposite is true as well.
And then there come skew.
So XQ tells us the asymmetry
of our distribution of data.
So this can be positive, negative
or undefined. And lastly,
kwan tiles are basically
ways of of dividing our, the,
the, the range of probability
distributions in our data.
And we can have several Quan tiles.
It's just a way of segmenting that data
out and there's a lot of statistical
features out there. We could have
added more and it, it would, you know,
it would affect our
prediction in different ways.
There's no way to fully know that. I
mean there's model evaluation techniques.
We'd have to try it out.
That's, that's part of the fun,
right? So, so there's that.
Now in this line, we're going to add
all those features to this dataset.
Once we have added those
features to our Dataset,
we can visualize the completed datasets
with the new features that we added
using the describe function.
So there we go.
We've got our new features that have been
added to our dataset. Boom. All right,
so now onto step five,
cat boost. So capp boost,
let's start with gradient boosting
because cap boost is a type of gradient
boosting. So grading, boosting,
it's a technique that can be used for
both regression and for classification
problems,
both types.
And it produces a prediction
model in the form of an ensemble.
That means many a collection
of weak prediction models.
Typically they use decision trees.
Now I want to note that gradient boosting
is not specific to decision trees.
We just tend to use decision trees
because they're easy to implement and they
tend to give good results.
But this say generalizable technique
that can be applied to any type of model.
Here we go for regression.
The idea,
and let's talk about it in the context
of decision trees for explanations sick.
So with gradient boosting,
we start off with a single tree and we
are training it on some distribution of
the data and it's going to build
a decision tree out of that data,
right to to be able to make
a prediction about that data.
Once we have that decision tree,
it's not going to be perfect.
They're going to be data points,
parts of the distribution that are off.
And that's the hidden state.
It could be better.
So we take that hidden state and we use
it to create yet another decision tree.
And so the idea is that we're focusing
on those data points that are not as, um,
encompassed in the regression line or the
regression model of the decision tree.
And we're going to focus on those data
points and more in the next decision tree.
And that's going to create a hidden state,
a representation of the data.
And we're going to do that again.
So we iteratively do that.
And so the equation then becomes h of x,
where x is all of the data is equal to
the first hidden state of x plus the
second hidden state of x, which are the
hidden states of each of these trees.
So in general,
boosting works by iteratively learning
week classifiers and adding them to a
final strong classifier.
And after a week learner is added,
the data's reweighted so that wrongly
classified examples gain weight and
correctly classified samples lose weight.
So in this way,
the weak learners are trained
to concentrate more on
the misclassified examples
as we can see in this image right here,
right? So, uh, great and boosting. It's
a type of grading dissent to algorithm.
And we can see this pseudo code
explains it very well, right?
So we have some data sample distribution
d and so for m equals one two M or m is
a number of base models. We want
to use, that's up for us to decide.
We can train our base model from
the training sample distribution,
compute the error,
and then adjust the distribution of the
next model to make the mistake of the
model more evidence than we output the
constructive based model and use that as
the input to the next iteration
for em, uh, models, right?
So however many models we
decide that we want to use,
and that's the basic idea
behind a gradient boosting,
iteratively improving a bunch of weak
learned weekly learned models until we get
a final strong model that is
better than the sum of its parts.
So now onto cat boost,
which is a version of gradient boosting.
There's actually several types of gradient
boosting techniques. Xg boost is one,
you know,
add a boost there a lot.
Okay,
so Yan index is the Russian Google and
they use gradient boosting a lot and they
use it to power a lot of their services.
So the idea is that for,
for cat boost,
cat booze stands for
categorical gradient boosting.
So what they do is
they say,
let's handle categorical
features automatically.
So without any explicit preprocessing
to convert categories into numbers,
cat boots will convert categorical values
into numbers using various statistics
and combinations of the existing
categorical features and combine both the
categorical and numerical features. And
so there are some advantages. There's uh,
you know,
usually tends to perform better than
the other types of gray and boosting.
As you can see here,
it has the lowest log loss values of
the gradient boosting algorithms that we
see here. So it's, it's really
popular, it's getting more popular.
And the Eli five of this,
as you can see here is we model the data
with simple models and then we find the
errors.
These errors signified data points that
are difficult to fit by the simple model.
And for later models iteratively,
we focus on those hard to fit
data points to get them right.
And in the end we combine
all the predictors together
by giving some weights to
each predictor.
Okay,
so let's go ahead and implement
this now here our handy, uh,
psych it learn library.
Thank you.
Psychic learn where we'll
use this pooling keyword
to collect the training data,
both the
input and the output data.
And then we'll initialize our regression
model using the regress regressor
keyword.
How many iterations?
Let's say 10,000 our loss function is
going to be as a Kaggle competition
suggest mean absolute error and the
type of boosting we're going to do,
which there are many types
is going to be ordered.
And now we go back and we will fit
the model to the training data and the
testing data.
Okay.
And printout the best score.
And now it's training.
And then when we see our score,
we'll see that our mean squared error
is 1.8599999999999999 which keeps us in
maybe top 300 to top
500 it could be better.
But my point is that this is our
first model, our first attempt.
So obviously it's not going to be the
best and we'll just iteratively improve.
Right? So that's, that's
the idea, right? So
yeah,
then we could, you know, submit
this for more. So let's get on.
Let's go on to step six,
which is implementing arch support vector
machine and the radial basis function
colonel. So in simple regression, we're
trying to minimize an error, right?
So regression models try to find the
relationship between variables, right?
One or more variables. And in a
support vector machine for regression,
we're trying to fit the air
within a certain threshold.
That's the difference. So
the idea is that the blue line can be
considered what's called the hyper plane.
The red lines are the boundary lines.
So the Blue Line is the line of best fit,
where the red lines are boundary lines
that we're going to decide by some value,
they're off from the hyper plane and
we're only going to consider data points
within this margin.
So only those data points,
there could be data
points all over the place.
And so simple regression will take
into account all of those data points.
But support vector regression will only
take into account the data points inside
of that margin, right? And those margins
are defined by the support directors,
which are the data points that are
closest to the line of best fit. So
okay,
that's our objective with the support
vector regression and the boundary lines.
We draw our either plus or
minus e distance from the
hyper hyperplane where he
has some value that we defined.
So we can define the equation
for our boundary line as such,
it's going to be uh, where you know y
equals mx plus B is the line. So, uh,
we'll,
we'll just add or subtract eight from
that equation and going to give us our
line of best fit.
So we're only so notice how there
are some data points outside of that,
but we're not considering,
those were only considering
and fitting our data to the,
to those data points inside
of those boundary lines.
And that's a support vector regression.
Okay.
So a lot of times we have what's
called a non linear decision boundary.
That means that a straight
line cannot fit the data,
which means our support vector machines
not going to work well and the weight.
And so on the left, as you
can see here, you know,
so we ideally we'd like to have the data
points separated such that if we were
to classify or to regress the data,
we would be able to linearly separate it
or linearly create the line of best fit.
You know, how do you make a line of best
fit for that data over here, it's hard.
Uh, it's impossible actually,
uh, in, in, in that space.
So what the solution to that is to use
what's called the kernel trick and the
kernel trick,
the,
a very simple way of thinking about
kernels are they are a similarity function
given two objects,
the colonel will output some similarity
scores and we can use those scores to
reframe the problem such that a linear
regression line or classification line
can either separate or find the
line of best fit for the data.
And there are a lot of different
types of kernels, right?
Okay.
So,
right inputs based a feature space,
there are many different
types of kernels out.
Therefore scms linear polynomial
Gaussian sigmoid. Uh, but in this,
in this, he's Galcion were
radio basis as we can see here,
but they're basically the
dot product of two vectors.
We can think of it that way.
And so this is the equation for
the support vector machine, right?
Where we have a weight value
that is learned through
some optimization technique,
light gradient descent. And then we
have the mx plus B, you know, the,
the line of best fit format as well.
And these are supported vectors.
So that's the basic idea behind
a support vector regression.
And that is not as used.
It's not used as much or understood
as much as a support vector machine
specifically for classification.
So I thought I wanted,
I wanted to shine some
light there on that, right?
It's usually used for classification
where a linear decision surface called a
hyperplane is used to
separate these classes.
Okay.
So what we're going to
do is we're going to uh,
build the support vector machine using
psychic learn and then we're going to
pick the ideal of hyper parameters
using a hyper parameter optimization
technique called grid search, which you're
going to pick a bunch of values for.
Each pair of values is going to
evaluate the validation error function,
then pick the pair that gives the minimum
value of the validation error function.
It's basically and try out the pears
until it finds the best pair for,
for our model. And so what we can see
here is that I've scaled those values.
I'm using my support vector, regression,
str, and these are my, you know, the,
the possible values that I've
defined for my grid search,
high parameter optimization technique.
So it's going to try out the pairs of
gamma and see to try to find those,
those ideal hyper parameters
for our model so that it's,
that's going to fit the data
and grid search CV does that,
the colonel is going to be right the
radial basis function as we saw before.
And then we'll make a prediction and then
we'll output the best CV score, which,
which is right here.
Now obviously we could do better.
There are different types of models
we could use. We only use two.
But remember our learning objectives here,
we're learning how to think like a data
scientist at least a little bit. Uh,
learning about the cat boost algorithm
and learning about the support vector
machine algorithm, specifically support
vector regression. And we did that.
So future ideas, uh, we
could try recurrent networks,
we could try genetic algorithms, we could
try ordinary differential equations.
And think about this as a time series
where there's just irregular data,
which Oh, nets are great for. So there's
a lot we can do and it's super exciting.
I hope you found this video useful.
I'm going to have a bunch of helpful
links in the video description.
What's a data science model
you want to learn more about?
Let me know in the comments section and
please subscribe for more programming
videos. For now, I'm going to find
a lasso. So thanks for watching.